O pior é quando a gente pede PR vocês
para sair vocês diz assim peça pro seu
pai a gente chega pai mãe disse para eu
pedir pro senhor para sair el disse peça
pra sua mãe a gente chega na mãe mãe o
pai disse para pedir pro senhor ele
disse peço pro seu pai parece que os
dois tá cada um com o toque de um lado
assim ó vai vai agora manda ele pedir
para mim chega na mãe a gente pede ele
disz pede pro seu pai na hora que a
gente sai ela fala olha Manda ele ir
para el para ti agora tu vai mandar ele
pedir para pedir para mim de novo para
para eu parciro parece um complô contra
mim que eu sou um menino tão bom meu
Deus nunca fiz nada de errado na minha
vida só uma vez que eu taquei uma casca
de ncer na cabeça da senhora mas foi sem
querer não foi nada que o qu ó Foi
homicídio culposo e ela nem morreu só
adoeceu